ich gebe das ergebnis der wahl zum
präsidenten des deutschen bundestages
bekannt
abgegebene stimmen 705 ungültige stimmen
eine gültige stimmen 704 mit ja haben
gestimmt 501 kolleginnen und kollegen
mit nein haben
damit dieser gerät über 355 stimmen 71
prozent statt und hat sich gerade so
rosig das ist mit der materie haben
angeblich so zum beispiel vorher von
ihnen haben gestimmt 173 kollegen
enthaltungen 30 30
herr dr wolfgang schäuble hat die
erforderliche mehrheit erhalten und ist
zum präsidenten des deutschen
bundestages gewählt
[Applaus]
mit diesmal geht es glaube ich war nur
darauf zu rechnen ist
eine fraktion sagt geräten herr
präsident ich nehme die wahl an haben so
damit steht der neue präsident des
deutschen bundestages fest volker kauder
bzw
der cdu-fraktionsvorsitzende
patrouilliert aus 70 auf die bundesland
punkt war die erste gratulantin hier bin
david ruwe und sehen wir da wirklich
jetzt kommt wolfgang schäuble vorgehen
das ist kein grüß gott onkel nur das
haben wir haben festgestellt dass wird
gar keine leichte aufgabe weil ich
glaube er weiß ganz genau weiß auch in
diesem moment ich schätze das ergebnis
hin zu schätzen
[Applaus]
jetzt ja auch mitglied im parlament ist
in seinem carsten schneider hier andrea
nahles die neue fraktionsvorsitzende
mein anton hofreiter nein ich glaube er
weiß ganz genau was auf ihn zukommt er
hatte jetzt ja auch zeit genug sie
darauf schon einzustellen
er ist viel zu erfahren und da nicht aus
sich auch schon gedanken zu machen
gemacht zu haben
wie gehe ich jetzt dann mit dem neuen
hand um ist sicherlich auch ein wenig
erleichtert dass er nun dieses amt auch
hat es wird für ihn doch einiges
leichter werden als das hat das wünschen
mal erwähnt ständige herumreisen in der
weltgeschichte
das muss man einfach sagen angela merkel
ist jetzt auch mal bei ihm und redet
vorne
hier sehen wir weitere gratulanten er
wird dieses haus auf seine art und weise
führen da können wir sicher sein auch
manche überraschung werden wir mit ihm
erleben diesem haus jetzt die art
schütze die erst sehr spät herzlich zu
dieser wahl gratulieren ich wünsche
ihnen und beispiel standen gesagt sollte
auch seine grünamt nämlich antje vollmer
in das präsidium des deutschen
bundestages
darüber habe jetzt war einmal jetzt
sorgen der offizielle wechsel gegeben
wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen der
bundestagspräsident wird demnächst von
rechts zu bekommen weil die rampe ist
norbert lammert kam ja immer von der
linken seite aber daran werden uns
sicherlich schnell gewöhnen es ist ja
auch für einen parlamentarier wie ihm er
ist der absolute spitzenreiter seit 1972
million verlangt ja auch eine krönung
natürlich hier im parlament jetzt
bundestagspräsident geworden zu sein wo
es keine steuer blockwart durch und
durch immer parlamentarier vom ersten
tag an als fraktionsvorsitzender als
abgeordneter er hat dieses parlament
doch muss man halt mal sagen nicht nur
geliebt sondern er hat es noch mit
geprägt und das ist jetzt schon für ihn
ein weiterer höhepunkt seiner karriere
und ich glaube er weiß dass auch in
diesem moment und irgendwie wird da auch
innerlich etwas angegriffen sein und
ergriffen sein jetzt selber zu seiner
ersten amtshandlung
muss ich selber drücken technische
probleme nicht mehr den gewünschten sie
machen mich lachen die probleme hat
wegen tonproblemen also fragen wir noch
mal von vorn
der bundespräsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren ich habe zunächst zu danken
ich danke ihnen für das vertrauen das
sie mir mit der wahl zum
bundestagspräsidenten entgegenbringen
ich danke hermann oder sollens mit
seiner langen parlamentarischen
erfahrung hat er die von mir übernommene
aufgabe diesen 19 deutschen bundestag
als dienstältester abgeordneter zu
eröffnen mit großer umsicht wahrgenommen
und er hat die herausforderungen für
unser parlament klar umrissen
ich möchte den vielen ausgeschiedenen
kolleginnen und kollegen danken
sie schauen zum teil auf
jahrzehntelanges parlamentarisches
wirken zurück ich nenne stellvertretend
heinz riesenhuber
er war gleich zweimal alterspräsident
bei der konstituierenden sitzung der
beiden zurückliegenden legislaturperiode
ich danke aus dem präsidium des 18ten
deutschen bundestags den ausgeschiedenen
vize-präsidenten lkb edelgard bulmahn
und johannes singhammer und ich danke
natürlich auch den beiden präsidentinnen
die nicht mehr dem nächsten präsidium
vermutlich angehören werden
aber das nehme ich jetzt die wahl vorweg
das ja auch ein bisschen schwierig vor
allen dingen aber meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren möchte ich norbert
lammert danken
er war zwölf jahre ein großartiger
bundestagspräsident
mit ihrer damals hatten eine ganz
besondere begabung als redner und sie
hatten immer klare vorstellungen davon
was dieses parlament leisten soll und
was es leisten kann wenn es denn will
ich freue mich die kollegen den kollegen
auf die neue aufgabe im parlament
schlägt das herz unserer demokratie und
ich freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit
mit ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wie mit allen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern die diesem haus dienen
ich bin parlamentarier aus leidenschaft
und ich habe meine abgeordnetentätigkeit
immer als hohe verantwortung und das
mandat als meine demokratische
legitimation verstanden ich habe im
übrigen im deutschen bundestag beides
erlebt
abgeordneter zu sein in der opposition
wie in einer regierungsfraktion zunächst
war ich zehn jahre in der opposition als
ich 1972 zum ersten mal als abgeordneter
im deutschen bundestag saß da wurde um
die ostverträge gestritten mit
leidenschaftlichen debatten damals in
bonn
die stimmung war aufgeladen und
überhaupt prägte seinerzeit eine extrem
spannungsvolle atmosphäre dieses landes
die gesellschaft der bundesrepublik
hatte sich seit mitte der 60er jahre in
einem bis dahin nicht gekannten maße
politisiert mobilisiert und polarisiert
geschadet hat es echt genauso übrigens
genauso wenig wie die erregung anfang
der 80er jahre
da war ich abgeordnete in der großen
regierungsfraktion als es etwa um den
nato doppelbeschluss ging
sieben jahre später fiel dann die mauer
veränderung
war also immer und vieles wird im
übrigen in der rückschau anders bewertet
als mitten im streit auch deshalb weil
ich also aus eigenem erleben weiß dass
erregung und krisen gefühle so neu nicht
wirklich sind auch deshalb sehe ich mit
gelassenheit den auseinandersetzungen
entgegen die wir in den kommenden jahren
führen werden
die wir im parlament zu führen haben
stellvertretend für die gesellschaft aus
der heraus wir gewählt sind denn diese
gesellschaft müssen wir nicht nur in
ihrem grundkonsens kann dann auch in
ihrer vielfalt und verschiedenheit
repräsentieren
wir dürfen das eine nicht gegen das
andere ausspielen
in einem demokratischen gemeinwesen ist
kein thema es wert über den streit das
gemeinsame in vergessenheit geraten zu
lassen
289 abgeordnete ziehen heute erstmals
ins parlament ein
das sind gut 40 prozent der aller
mitglieder dieses hauses selten
unterschied sich ein bundestag so sehr
von seinem vorgänger wie dieser sieben
parteien und sechs fraktionen so viele
gab es seit 60 jahren nicht mehr
und diese neue konstellation hier im
haus spiegelt die veränderungen wieder
die unsere gesellschaft erlebt
verunsicherungen wachsen angesichts des
raschen wandels durch globalisierung und
digitalisierung zusammenhänge lösen sich
auf zugehörigkeiten brechen auf neue
entstehen alte gewissheiten und
identitäten werden in frage gestellt und
neue vermeintliche gewissheiten werden
in stellung gebracht gegen zunehmende
sorgen und zweifel das menschliche
bedürfnis nach geborgenheit in
vertrauten lebensräumen
es trifft auf eine zunehmende als
ungemütlich empfundene welt voller
konflikte krisen kriege medial präsenten
schrecken und vor diesem hintergrund
verschärft sich die tonlage der
gesellschaftlichen debatten
all das können wir übrigens vielerorts
in europa beobachten und mit dem
ungeheuer schnellen gesellschaftlichen
wandel den wir erleben geht eine
fragmentierung unserer debatten und
aufmerksamkeiten einher
und das stellt die politische ordnung
die demokratischen institutionen und
verfahren vor große herausforderungen
jedem
erscheint etwas anderes wichtig jeder
scheint gelegentlich nur noch seine
eigene probleme wahrzunehmen und es gibt
nicht mehr das eine thema das
überhandnehmen von möglichkeiten und
optionen kann auch überfordern
über dieses unbehagen im kapitalismus
hat uwe jean heuser schon 2000
geschrieben wie alles ist übrigens auch
freiheit durch über mass gefährdet
und deswegen müssen wir immer wieder die
richtige balance auch im umgang mit
freiheit lernen
hinzu kommt der wandel der medien und
ihre nutzung durch die veränderung in
der informationstechnologie die
zersplitterung in viele teile
öffentlichkeiten führt dazu dass uns
eine erkennbar gemeinsame sicht auf
politische prioritäten verloren geht und
da kann dieses parlament ein ort der
bündelung der fokussierung der
konzentration auf die wichtigen fragen
unserer gesellschaftlichen zukunft in
deutschland wie in europa sein
wir abgeordnete liebe kollegen kollegen
sind für die mitbürger im wahlkreis
manchmal fast eine art ombudsmann mit
unserer arbeit und unseren begegnungen
vor ort vermitteln wir diese
wirklichkeit auf die ebene der
bundespolitik und unsere vielzahl an
erfahrungen und qualifikationen aus
beruflicher sozialer ehrenamtlicher
tätigkeit das bildet eine ganze menge
expertise
vielleicht wissen und fühlen wir
abgeordnete durch unsere verwurzelung
bei den menschen manchmal besser als die
forschungsinstitute was die menschen
wirklich bewegt und zugleich
und zugleich sind wir alle wie artikel
38 unseres grundgesetzes sagte
abgeordnete des ganzen volkes und dazu
müssen wir diese vielzahl von interessen
meinungen befindlichkeiten mit den
begrenzt halten und der endlichkeit der
realität zusammenbringen und das zwingt
zu kompromissen und zu entscheidungen
durch mehrheit
und je besser das gelingt umso weniger
fühlen sich menschen in der
demokratischen wirklichkeit
zurückgelassen
immanuel kant dem wir viele gedanken von
rechtsstaat und republik verdanken hat
ja gesagt ich drücke es halb mit meinen
worten aus handlich stets so dass das
prinzip bei einer handlung immer auch
das prinzip der handlungen aller anderen
sein könnte dass es immer auch
allgemeines gesetz sein könnte also
handle so dass menschliches miteinander
nicht zusammenbreche wenn alle so
handelten wie du selbst und das für die
kolleginnen und kollegen gilt gerade
auch für parlaments abgeordnete und das
ist eine gute maxime für unser
repräsentativen system
auch die vertretung partikularinteressen
darf wie alles nicht exzessiv werden
andere demokratien in der welt sind da
übrigens schon weit auf die abschüssige
bahn geraten
was aber sehr wohl sein darf und sein
muss das ist dass der parlamentarische
prozess hier im außen sichtbar macht wie
schwierig sowohl die durchsetzung als
auch der ausgleich von interessen in
einer liberalen demokratie ist und da
darf streit nicht nur sein
das geht nur über streit den größen wir
führen und den müssen wir aushalten
ertrag und demokratischer streit ist
notwendig aber es ist streit nach regeln
und es ist mit der bereitschaft
verbunden die demokratischen verfahren
zu achten und die dann uns so zustande
gekommenen mehrheitsentscheidungen nicht
als illegitim oder verräterisch oder
sonstwie zu denunzieren
sondern die beschlüsse der mehrheit so
akzeptieren das ist parlamentarische
kontrolle kultur und da kommt es dann
auch auf den stil an
indem wir uns hier streiten und indem
wir füreinander respekt signalisieren
können
es gab in den vergangenen monaten in
unserem land töne der verächtlichmachung
und erniedrigung
ich finde das hat keinen platz in einem
zivilisierten miteinander
die überwältigende mehrheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
will ein zivilisiertes miteinander und
ihn aufgewühlten zeiten wie unseren
wächst das bedürfnis nach formen des
verhaltens über die man lange nicht mehr
geredet hat weil man sie als
selbstverständlich ansehen
es wird wieder über anstand gesprochen
sogar bücher werden darüber geschrieben
kommen auf die bestseller-listen
und es wird auch über die frage
gesprochen wie wir in der gesellschaft
miteinander umgehen soll
respekt füreinander haben nicht jeden
persönlichen spielraum maximal ausnutzen
ein offenes ohr haben für die argumente
des anderen ihn anerkennen mit seiner
anderen meinung es geht um fairness
hundertprozentige gerechtigkeit gibt es
nicht aber fairness ist möglich in dem
sinne dass sich möglichst alle
angesprochen fühlen und nicht
ausgeschlossen bleiben und die art und
die art wie wir hier miteinander reden
die kann vorbildlich seien für die
gesellschaftliche debatte prügeln
sollten wir uns hier nicht wie es ja in
europa zum teil auch in anderen
parlamenten bis mir eingeschickt
wir sollten es übrigens auch nicht
verbal tun
wir können viel mehr zeigen dass man
sich streiten kann ohne dass es
unanständig wird und dazu müssen wir
zeigen dass auch ein bundestag mit sechs
fraktionen schafft motor da ist
entscheidungen herbeizuführen die als
legitim empfunden werden
das parlament besteht aus abgeordneten
und diese abgeordneten sind nicht
abgehoben wie so gern oberflächlich
dahin geredet wird wir sind aus der
mitte der bürgerinnen und bürger gewählt
aber niemand vertritt alleine das volk
so etwas wie volkswille entsteht
überhaupt erst in und mit unseren
parlamentarischen entscheidungen
deswegen
deswegen haben wir die pflicht diesen
ort wer zu halten als ort des
nachvollziehbaren sachlichen auch
emotionalen streits ja auch gefühle
gehören dazu
stellvertretend für die mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger die dinge die alle angehen
argumente argumentativ gegeneinander
oder miteinander auszumachen
und dann mit mehrheit entscheiden wir
müssen das vertrauen in die rebellin das
repräsentative prinzip wird das stärken
das ist übrigens keine nur nationale
frage die europäischen oder westlichen
werte die grundlage unserer
verfassungsmäßigen ordnung singh
jährigen vielerorts fragil und sie
erfreuen sich doch zugleich weltweit
großer attraktivität freiheit
rechtsstaatlichkeit sozialer
zusammenhalt ökologische nachhaltigkeit
ohne parlamentarismus geht alters nicht
nach ernsthaften streit der meinungen
stellvertretend für alle bürgerinnen und
bürger entscheidungen zu treffen
die befriedende wirkung die das hat wenn
es gelingt die brauchen wir überall in
der welt in einer welt wo ja überall
immer mehr menschen nicht nur anspruch
auf wirtschaftliche teilhabe sondern
auch auf politische mitsprache erheben
und in zeiten zunehmender globalisierung
heißt dass auch die kompliziertheit
unserer welt auszuhalten
aber wir haben ja zugleich auch die
chance der welt die sich uns näher zu
zeigen dass der parlamentarismus etwas
taugt dass er funktioniert dass er zu
lösungen für die probleme und
herausforderungen fähig ist
norbert lammert hat immer sehr elegant
die tage an denen der sprach danach
gefragt was an ihn
in vergangenen jahren und jahrhunderten
geschah und dann was uns das erinnern
sollte und ich will dass heute noch
einmal im sinne einer kleinen omas ton
also um es chronologisch rückwärts zu
machen
dieser vierundzwanzigster oktober ist
der tag der vereinten nationen
1945 trat am 24 oktober die charta der
vereinten nationen in kraft
am 24 oktober 1929 ende der am schwarzen
donnerstag die jahrelange außer der new
yorker börse und es begann die
weltwirtschaftskrise mit allen ihren
folgen und am 24
oktober 1648 wurde der westfälische
friede zur beendigung des
dreißigjährigen kriegs unterzeichnet ein
krieg an dessen beginn wir uns kommendes
jahr erinnern
herfried münkler hat ihm gerade ein opus
magnum gebiet mit dem thema zeigt dass
dieser bis heute längste krieg auf
deutschem boden
zugleich übrigens der erste im vollen
sinne europäische krieg dass dieser
krieg uns besser als alle späteren
konflikte die kriege unserer gegenwart
verstehen lässt wer es nicht glaubt lese
einmal simplicissimus von grimmelshausen
noch einmal nach es übrigens in meinen
wahlkreis geschrieben
all das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
erinnert uns an den charakter der
aufgaben die vor uns liegen und es
erinnert uns daran dass wir die
entscheidungen die wir hier treffen in
welt politische zusammenhänge
einzubetten haben europa die
globalisierung das ist heute der rahmen
für das was wir hier debattieren und
entscheiden
und das hat nichts mit einem aufgeben
nationaler selbstbestimmung zu tun und
schon gar nichts mit einem aufgeben des
anspruchs dass dies hier der ort ist an
dem immer neu die souveränität des
deutschen volkes greifbar und wirklich
wird sondern es beschreibt die aufgabe
der wir gerecht werden müssen den weg
einer selbstbewussten einordnungen immer
weitere zusammenhänge zu finden mit dem
ziel dazu beizutragen in dieser welt
unsere zukunft gestalten zu können
und dass wir uns in solche öffnung zur
welt und einordnung noch selbst erkennen
dass wir bleiben was wir ja irgendwie
fühlen dass wir sind im guten zum
beispiel unserer parlamentarischen
ordnung wie im schlechten was bereits
nationale schicksalsgemeinschaft nicht
werden abstreifen können uns doch aus
dem wird doch immer wieder neu gutes zu
entwickeln uns bemühen dass wir alters
bleiben ohne uns abzuschotten oder uns
bequem rauszuhalten
darum liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
geht es in der präambel
[Musik]
in der präambel unseres grundgesetzes
von 1949 die wir 1990 im wiedervereinten
deutschland fortgeschrieben haben heißt
es von dem willen beseelt als
gleichberechtigtes glied in einem
vereinten europa dem frieden der welt zu
dienen hat sich das deutsche volk kraft
seiner verfassungsgebenden gewalt dieses
grundgesetz gegeben und dies hier liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist der ort an
dem wir diesen willen gestalt geben und
dafür
und dafür hat und seine wieder
gewachsene zahl von bürgerinnen und
bürgern gewählt der trend zu höheren
wahlbeteiligung bei den letzten
landtagswahlen hat sich ja auch im bund
fortgesetzt ich denke das zeigt dass
erwartungen gestiegen sind und wenn wir
diese erwartungen einigermaßen erfüllen
können wir uns im land einen großen
dienst erweisen
steigen die erwartungen sind also eine
chance auch wenn es zur wahrheit gehört
dass in dieser welt immer neuer akteure
und immer dichterer verflechtungen die
realität komplizierter wird und unsere
handlungsspielräume nicht immer nur
wachsen zwischen beidem müssen bereits
parlament unseren weg finden
ich freue mich auf unsere arbeit hier in
den kommenden vier jahren herzlichen
dank
aus allen fraktionen darauf hatte ich
gerade sagen sie hat ein zeitzeuge der
parlamentsgeschichte den letzten 45
jahre gesprochen und er hat gesagt dass
demokratischer staat notwendig sei
mehrheitsentscheidungen sind notwendig
nicht als bildet ihn zu demonstrieren
und es komme auf den spielern in dem wir
uns gestalten klar richtung hardy und
der vorurteile unsere erste berichte
oder deren erfahrungen werden muss ich
sagen die man ja schon im landtags
fraktionen im landtag landtagen gemacht